منذ بدايه العام الجاري تتعرض مناطق
مختلفه من سوريا لهجمات جويه تقول دمشق
انها اسرائيليه ففي الثاني من يناير
الماضي قتل اربعه اشخاص بينهم جنديان
سوريان جراء قصف استهدف مطار دمشق الدولي
وفي الثلاثين من الشهر نفسه قصفت طائرات
مجهوله قوافل شاحنات قادمه من العراق داخل
الاراضي السوريه بينما ذكرت وسائل اعلام
اسرائيليه ان الهجمات استهدفت قافله تابعه
لفصائل ايرانيه وفي التاسع عشر من فبراير
قال الاعلام الرسمي السوري لاسرائيل قصفت
اهدافا في محيط دمشق ما اسفر عن سقوط خمسه
قتله بينما افادت رويترز ان الهجوم
الصاروخيه استهدف اجتماعا لخبراء ايرانيين
وسوريين معنيين بتطوير الطائرات المسيره
والصواريخ
وفي الثاني والعشرين من الشهر نفسه
في حلب لقصف صاروخي اسرائيلي حسب مصادر
سوريه وذلك بعد اسبوعين من قصف مماثل
لمدرج مطار حلب الدولي تسبب في خروجه عن
الخدمه
ويوم الخميس الماضي اعلنت وكاله الانباء
السوريه ان الدفاعات الجويه تصدت عدوان
اسرائيلي بعدد من الصواريخ استهدف مناطقها
في محيط العاصمه